بخلاف علاقته مع القوه الامنيه يتزايد
المختلفون مع الرئيس التونسي منذ قراراته
مساء الخامس والعشرين من يوليو 2021 التي
اعتبرها خصومهم انقلاب على الدستور
ومؤسسات الدوله تباعا بدا الاشتباك بين
مؤسسه الرئاسه ومؤسسات وكيانات منها من
كان ابدى قدرا من التفهم والهدوء ازاء
قرارات رئيس المتلاحقه لعام كامل مدد
الرئيس حاله الطوارئ ومن ثقنه تابعه للحرس
الوطني دعى الشرطه والجيش ومن سماهم
القضاه الشرفاء للتصدي للمتامرين على
الدوله وفق تعبيره مضيفا انتقادات للعمل
النقابي كان لها ما بعدها قبل تلك
التصريحات بيوم فقط خرج قيس سعيد معلقا
للمره الاولى على التراجع الحاد في نسب
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه لكنه
فجاه متابعه بالدعوه لقراءه تلك النسب
بشكل مختلف متهما البرلمان السابق بالعبث
بالدوله والتحول لم مؤسسه داخل الدوله
يفقد عمره مشيرا لان الاكثريه لا تكترث
بالبرلماني ولا تثق فيه فهل تنذر هذه
التصريحات بغموض مصير البرلمان المقبل
خاصه بالنظر لنسب المشاركه المتدنيه التي
تمخض عنها
البرلمان كان اولى المؤسسات التي
استهدفتها قرارات الرئيس مساء ال 25 من
يوليو قبل عام ونصف تجميدا ثم حلا بالكامل
ولم يكن المؤسسه الوحيده بل وقع اشتباك مع
القضاه ومجلسهم الاعلى افضى الى حل المجلس
بالكامل بل اقاله عشارات القضاه في وقت
لاحق في المقابلتهم سعيد بتوظيف القضاء
العسكريه للانتقام من خصومه وفق تصريحات
احمد نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه خلاص المحامون
في تونس ايضا تظاهروا مطلع العام غضبا مما
اعتبره تراجعا في الحقوق والحريات ومن ثقل
وطاه التضخم والازمه الاقتصاديه يمارس
الرئيس التونسي السلطه منفردا منذ عام
ونصف ويتولى وحده اقاله المسؤولين
التنفيذيين وتعيين غيرهم قبل يومين اجرى
تعديل وزاريلا محدودا دون ابداء اسباب ولا
يكف عن تعليق كل ازمات البلاد في رقبه من
يتهموهم دوما بالخيانه والفساد دون ان
يسمى حب واللافت ان الازمات تتفاقمه رغم
اقصائي كل خصوم الرئيس